[Music]
by a nation today we're doing word that
one stopped the show where we go to one
uniquely worth it place to try one
uniquely worth it - today we go to Niko
it's a little bit north of Japan is that
right no subclass north of Tokyo yeah
not north of Japan that's the ocean
today we're gonna be eating foods in
boxes right bento boxes so today we're
having a very special a very unique in a
very pricey in exquisite bento box in
preparation of this video we bought some
icky been which are been does you buy at
the train station and we're gonna enjoy
that on the way do it
I love train food let's go
[Music]
we're going up on a Thursday to eat this
very special bento box and what is a
bento box you pass it's like the
Japanese version of a lunch box invite
bento box at a train station but
different train stations throughout the
country will have different bento boxes
normally get this one but did them a big
one yeah fancy one tofu and it gives you
the allergen information with these
great little drawings aren't these lame
this
yeah the decently baby
no grudge soon's got the pickled plum at
the top I bought the trifecta cucumber
egg and crab I have one of your no good
good I smell it you didn't even eat it
yet your navel
we've made it yes we're at Niko Niko
Hodgins what are the bento boxes let's
go
peaches peach peach balanced water mode
oh okay here we are
we've made it yeah look at this fish
illustration that's got Adam written all
over it
we ate what can you tell me about this
one here that comes with a shovel
it's a agasshi it's kind of type of
sushi Oh what you know it expected to be
swaddled like that yeah it's beautiful
cloth we've got the cold
/ - sua an Akuma solution but you guys
are no tattoos nobody must Tamra coitus
home did to us an original nickel my
document or a sanity documents so can
you tell me how did you get in to start
making bento boxes Pomona ha daisuki
their needs at anemone nico de masas
results critical malta has a metal
Nicholas Nick corner are choosing to go
to you poking me dreaming up Ciccone
muscle attack tiny tear Masuka you men
on this demo armory muscle or even up
there Misuzu Shira Booga diacetyl touch
their souls good homebodies tight what
is the bento and what does it mean to
you but snow event hola a cube until
their toxin event or not I know you may
not have been to three discs Iraq euro
Condit octa many it cost attacked
America talking to Serena its abundant
this is a sake that they make here in
Nikko I believe it's unpasteurized so it
needs to stay refrigerated or else it'll
spoil which is I think pretty unique and
I just learned from Rea that when you
pour sake you hold you hands label up
teamwork make the dream work come by
[Music]
all right let's do the bento do the
bento is that a dance of yours we'll
find out later that's a dance or not hey
Nico my zoki bento - Noah
so no my sake or dietary event no
open-toed Escarra so no we see my
zucchini only see a car on Iona Oh God
so have a spoon a bit so here we're
starting with the hidden gold bento nice
ok a little stamp but the data was made
ready ready oh oh it's got a nice heft
to it I could definitely eat a lot of
fried rice with this thing
ob hey open both level yeah I think
there's a double decker we got here
focus in the first alert here we have a
piece of egg it was the height of bed of
then jeez it's like oh my it's very
thick Wow so with an egg on a bed of egg
and on her knees right is it better rice
you know how like Disneyland has themed
desserts and treats this out does any of
those either that mess
oh wow it is a very reminiscent of like
packaged cheese but the fact that it's
egg like this is egg any beef you have a
mess mmm a little fatty
wow there's like hormones in it the next
mentor the one we came all the way to
Nico for layana's tell us about what
this bento mid-corner is you know Cory
Minooka Pomona toka so cos I know mean
imagine me it's good that I can only
suppose I was able to meet ed Korea
gotta you know no no bento what's
critical Thomas - ow Okinawa ho seat or
attack the totally forget it a imagine
our team I know Ventura local Nick
corner ah yes I mean no it took me to
Korean star my world must have to wanna
do karissa grimace Nicole of Tononi
cooperative then talk or get because
Karen or Aquatica Fox una hora tada
mokona niconico Angie they were but you
know a given walls better climbers token
unique umezaki mental ah no Johanna and
the menorah is two kinds of Miley honey
so cuz I got any higher and I know that
it's souk Abajo see this I mean if you
like a wrapping paper this is clearly
the superior original version of that
all right I'm going in
look at these beautifully engraved
chopsticks and see the craftsmen work on
the back all right you ready with a box
oh I love just moving my head around to
see how the light changes and hits it
like it really has this three
dimensionality to it do this for a
second see that's a buck dance are you
ready for the big reveal
I'm ready okay so there's another
protective layer Wow this is the king of
benzos the ingredients here are
assembled because there are his favorite
foods
yeah public in time
whoa you know those uh towels that when
you pour water on them they expand and
become a full-size towel and reminds me
of that it's a very definitive I'm not
sure what it's dressed with but it's the
savoriness is heightened we have a
mushroom shitake mushroom your favorite
yeah because I'm a funny guy
generally marinated mushroom cap Tochigi
no so T value ergo Lanka No Go Go se yo
until tomorrow
ah no here no Soto area of China's the
locket Akkadian instead Togawa
canary ITA I know he Matsuri Oni mr.
Leamas
now Sato Briand the Chateaubriand this
steak I would almost want to say it has
no business being in a box I need to
have another way I don't even know what
happened to me just now don't don't go
too hard with those job sex Steven
there's the enzyme I bet I could get a
cleaner bite than that
look at that you are literally a
marshmallow with me yeah cascara kuru
maybe on your home d'Ivoire Kolkata
bizarre to stay that's come on a team of
Syrah a vino Emami de tocar el mommy ha
kya dr. Cara a guru Mahavira satto neato
neato is their motto a cocoon are my dad
who knew knob you can indiscernible and
only two integers so Cara
Co TAS MELAS kuru step it's good to mask
our demo tendonosis ionizing night
divine yogic Ariana the only horse cow
steamer fan okay
shrimp
the shell those little legs are still
here
oh come to meet Ron remember when we had
to peel the grapes eating this so sweet
sweet shrimp mean and the live moments
ago let's go for this background this is
what is in their award-winning bento box
is there a particular name for what
we're having here my sushi we cheat
suppressed trout sushi - no masses issue
our duo SANDAG necklace katsu curry dad
school eating it's it's cool no money
hungry super tell Romeo toy today was
like an old cake on that is Sebastiano
tell security reasons
ok I've never seen sushi like this
almost like the cars in Japan
aww blocky Wow yeah the flesh is very
grapefruit like this is not a one biter
I'm sure I'm doing it
no Lego block of trout we're checking
her head and you know that means it's so
tall it's so satisfying to bite through
oh my goodness look at that
look at it
it's so satisfying that it's compressed
like that nickel amoeba human-animal
Cora on Tony Tony oh that's good
sighs oh no McCulloch Kato to
Connecticut on screen a shinobi NE magu
no da esquina caviar no no she has an of
oregano caviar
so here we have tofu skin mounded with
caviar and then gilded with a touch of
gold it's all the time do we bring the
shovel back into play here here we go Oh
God I'm sorry I almost got all of the
caviar we're about to finish a jar of
caviar and about two bites here a lot
lower you know on a caviar - oh wow it's
such an interesting texture it looks
like you pulled your linen out of the
laundry machine too early it's still
glistening with soap really good yeah
it's literally bursting with flavor
last but not least crab time Kurama Vern
you are hokkaido de patata no mo mo h da
mama and all mm us Eskimo Orson or
terrible Gallo famous misrata mama to go
along this moto zero courtesan on there
well Canova's oh no Tara whadda you know
Sankyo current oh sorry Scotty mother
the surrogate or ni parwa
I know Lunia Scotty T to the negative
Iowa we can someone not eat like loss
did you see this crab when it was a live
dragon
it is like the closest thing to a
prehistoric beast I've ever seen in real
life
no wow look at how thick and plump oh my
goodness yeah it is like a mess you know
what's amazing about the crab is that
all of its meat is good to go you take
away its shell and then the rest of it
is siliceous here's where shovel time
comes into play ready Annie pull this
crab news and we struck rice I'm gonna
build one more Annie here ever see the
best of luck let's do desserts this
bento box comes with a side of dessert
huh oh it's a two-layer thing here Wow
what this is like in the office when Jim
put white flavors in the jello what is
it inside sweet beans
cheers Cheers oh it's like a bath bomb
of flavor this is crazy here you can
have the rest of this thank you hmm it's
so good oh so here we have this this is
mochi Rathlin tea leaf smell that look
at that
Oh big and juicy that is
wow that's incredible last but not least
sunflowers I don't know what's in here
it looks like a cake this is a sunflower
because now we're in the summer and
they'll change this flower depending on
the season
[Music]
bento boxes there's so much more than
just food and I think that is what makes
it so beautiful its artistry and
personality and love the things that you
really cherish you place in this box
it's less of a delivery method and more
of a talent place for it to his ID
[Music]
oh yes